you have to build up trust over time
this doesn't really happen overnight so
when I've done a million it was the
groundwork that I probably put in the
year or two before that that enabled me
to hit a million I suppose it's just
coming back to the relationship piece
having regular contact so it's just
building up that trust because I think
msps HR they do look at agencies
sometimes like just going off and doing
their own thing speaking to the business
when they're not allowed and basically
breaking the rules whereas I make sure
not just myself I'm HMR team that
doesn't happen because it takes ages to
build up the trust but then something
that happens that can just knock it all
down straight away